when you think back to all of the
internal and external facets of Aaron
Bell the hair the look the gait the
voice and then also the backstory and
what we learn about her what was as far
as the internal and the external the
most important things that helped you
unlock her I mean I always start
internally just because that's the it
that's basically how I choose a role
because it affects me emotionally and
and also I'm obviously very director
driven so I go okay what's my connection
to the director and what are they going
to bring out of me and I think I'd
already met Karen and we'd we'd
established a relationship prior to
reading the script so I sort of knew her
sensibilities and what she was aiming to
do with her career and the story she was
trying to tell and I just found Aaron
deeply emotional because of her I think
the way in which she's made choices that
have left her incredibly scarred and
damaged and the way in which she's
somehow trying to heal those even though
she knows she's not going to save her
own life and the idea of saving her
daughter's life or giving her daughter a
different life to hers even though she's
made terrible mistakes in raising her
child that to me is deeply emotional and
so that's how I went in and then out of
that came how do we build this this
woman externally and I know people have
said well why does she look so damaged
but I think when you know why well I
mean but it's interesting because you
know she's she's not 60 she's she it's
17 years after she's sort of late 40s
but she's really really you know she's
in flicked
a lot of damage on her body and
obviously her psyches been damaged but
she's got she doesn't care anymore about
what she's what's going to happen to her
and she has a line in the film witches
and as an actor you're always looking
for these these what I call the jewels
because they're the things that give you
the history where she says I don't care
what happens to me well a person that
doesn't care what happens to them is a
very dangerous person so that was sort
of those little things and then
obviously the the line that the daughter
says where she talks about how I you
know don't tell me how your mother used
to burn you with cigarettes and the way
well that there is in one line a whole
history of her abuse and the way in
which she's been raised by her own
mother which has caused incredible
damage so that's the beginning Matt you
and Phil have been writing together for
many years I just learned backstage that
you've known each other since you were
about 18 years old Matt can you tell me
a little bit about where kind of the
genesis or germ of this script came from
for you guys yeah we um you know we
obviously love stories about LA because
where I grew up here Phil in car and I
both lived here for a long time
loved cop movies and always wanted to
kind of work on one have been inspired
by those films of the 70s and we had an
idea we had a structure in mind for how
to tell this cop story about you know
someone ultimately searching for
themselves we had this circular
structure in mind and so we this is
about 10 years ago we would pick it up
and put it down and we had some kind of
touchstone scenes that supported this
back and forth with the past but what
really made it click for us was when we
finally hit upon the character of Aaron
Bell it had to be this woman it had to
be air and it had to involve this
relationship with her daughter and from
that on kind of the why of telling this
story and the really fell into place and
made it not easy but easier and then
Phil given the fact that you and Karan
are not only
professional partners but partners in
life as well
at what point like do you decide like
now's the time for me to tell Karan
about this and hope that she might do it
or is she in on it from the very
beginning
she's always aware of what we're doing
our whereabouts at all times creatively
and strange if she wasn't makes it sound
like I'm like ruling that with an iron
artistic panopticon we we sort of knew
we really always aim now is this kind of
family unit to do these things together
so we're always aiming toward Karen's
vision and voice and we see it as trying
to see we have this story and then this
character and then we want to see it
through Karen's eyes and then we want to
help however we can
in a coalesced process seeing try to see
her through Nicole's eyes as well all
together and I think that we that in
this case very early we sort of knew
what was important and talked to that
about with Corrin before we even got too
deeply into the structural stuff and it
was just the emotional core of this
story and wanting to tell a story about
this woman who could be everything in
this movie who wasn't just a vehicle to
deliver a story that we really were
intensely invested in together telling
this story about a woman who could be
who lived every facet of a life that we
could possibly try to portray so we did
that very we early knew what the what
the heart was for us and then Karan
would kind of we now know I've known
each other for a really long time
plumbing to a lot of our key
collaborators Teddy the composer and so
we can kind of organically move forward
all together so but while we're writing
the script Karan is already working on
the visuals for the movie because we've
talked it through in detail and Teddy is
already writing music based on the
script and plumbing is probably the
second or third person who ever reads
the script so there's this sort of
organic progression
Carn from your from your standpoint what
was most important to you as far as
creating this intensely unsettling off
seedy atmosphere that you feel so
viscerally as you watch this movie um
that's an interesting question kind of a
hard one to answer but I feel like I
wanted us to what felt most important to
me was that as you watched the movie
whether you like it or not you start to
become intimate with this character you
start to feel closer to understanding
something about her whether you like her
or don't like her or sympathize with her
don't I just wanted the audience to have
the experience of really watching a life
lived and the choices be considered and
the sense that in some ways she's made a
very very bold brave step to be
accountable for for some of her mistakes
those who don't want spoilers who are
watching this on YouTube come back after
you've watched the movie but for those
of you who are gonna stick around and be
a little bit brave and bold plummy I'd
be curious to know from your point of
view how the kind of I mean this movie
pulls the rug from under the viewer in
the coolest way 15 minutes from the end
how did that device infill in math
script affect the way you approach this
as the editor well I always knew that I
had to find a way foreign car and
obviously was doing this in the
direction but find a way to make it
believable that that spoiler first scene
really the first scene so to have that
be the believable in the end and hat
what ended up I think being the biggest
challenge with the film in the editing
was how much information do we give and
when do we give it enough for people to
hold on to but not so much that they get
kind of lost in the in the in the forest
so yeah mr. Turkey Fred from your point
of view man you've done films of so many
different kind of
levels of scope and budget and you know
production scale what Springs to Maya if
I were to ask you what the biggest
challenge was on this one from a
production standpoint it's funny we talk
a lot about the challenges and as we've
been discussing the movie lately and I
sort of think about the movie in two
very distinct ways one the sort of
gargantuan distance between our set of
resources and the ambition that carne
implicitly brings to her work and that
was integral to the script itself the
the scope the scale the time periods
shooting in LA is the most expensive
place to shoot in the world to bank
heist because one isn't enough and
various things that you've just seen so
that level of just production DNA
coupled with what we had was sort of an
impossible task and yet my experience of
making the movie because you have first
of all the script that's so polished and
so precise and kind of you couldn't take
the Dominos out which really tried we're
like we don't have enough time to shoot
this so where does it and we just
couldn't find it and and then you have a
director who's just so experienced she's
walking on set with so much experience
shooting film and television and huge as
you talk about different scope and scale
and big studio movies and Indies and so
has been through it all and brings just
an insane amount of preparation
meticulous planning for every scene and
very every set piece in a way that kind
of just makes our jobs effortless so
then you also have you know one of our
greatest actors working at the height of
her powers and all I remember is just a
responsibility a feeling intense sort of
sacred responsibility to just kind of
protect that and encourage it and and
just create a bubble where they were
just free to work as there's already two
great producers when I joined the
literal family as you noted so my
recollection of the movie is actually
quite effortless even though I know that
there was a point where it felt really
daunting was there anything I'm thinking
back to the myriad crazy things that
Aaron Belle does in this movie from
putting Petra's very alive body in the
trunk to getting shot to the very
friendly visit at the guy's house who's
in that hospital bed was there anything
that you read in the script for a first
time in youth
oh my god why am I gonna be able to do
this did anything give you pause I'm so
crazy that no no I just saw it as like
okay these let's go I've never been to
these places and I'm ready to to do this
but what was gray and this is where you
always go ah this is why you never fight
anything because of the limitations of
the budget we were shooting in real
locations we were hustling to get things
done every day we were losing shots and
Karen was having to go I I wanted that
shot so badly but I'm gonna give that
but you know the house where I pay the
visit the home visit and that house
actually had was it 20 or 30 cats living
in it yeah so it smelt of cats piss
it was so putrid when we walked in but
that's fantastic is an actor because it
was like I walked in I couldn't wait to
get out of there but all of that plays
in to you know and because there were
those locations that was fantastic
and that's why then we were shooting you
know at night in really dangerous places
and that is that's there you can feel it
or I could feel it in my body and in the
end the way in which I would move and
people talk to me about how I started to
walk I wasn't aware of any of that that
just started to happen because of the
internal injuries because of my own
depression while I was making it and it
just started to weigh on me well those
things are invaluable as an actor and
that's why I think you never you never
fight anything whatever you're given
whether it's a budget location suddenly
you have to lose scene suddenly things
have to be rewritten you go with the
flow and it's one of the greatest
lessons and I actually learnt it
originally from kübra
and Kubrick no matter what happened he
would change and make the scene better
and he would never go and fight for a
location if it was too expensive he was
like huh we'll get something better and
he that's how he operated and then he
would sort of massage things and watch
things and watch them percolate and
adjust accordingly
and it was one of the greatest lessons
as an actor to start with him and then
to keep applying it through my whole
career well I thank you all for making
our brains explode tonight thank you so
much